bonjour et bienvenue dans ce cas les
émissions qui parlent de livres qui
parlent de sciences humaines
pour ce sixième épisode on va se braquer
une notion qui a été amené par
l'historien pierre nora
il s'agit de l'événement monstre c'est
une notion riche qui a pour objet le
lien entre l'événement médiatique et
l'histoire comme d'habitude on va
l'aborder un peu en trois temps c'est à
dire que d'abord on va présenter son
auteur ensuite on va parler un petit peu
de la notion essayé de l'expliquer à
définir et ensuite on va essayer de voir
comment cette notion on peut l'aborder
au regard des évolutions qu'il ya eu
depuis que cette notion a été abordée
c'est à dire plus ou moins aux alentours
des années 70 et 80
et d
thür
donc quand nora est né en 1931 et est
issu d'une famille bourgeoise qu'il est
juif donc pendant la guerre il va
d'abord essayer de se cacher dans une
pension une fonction dont il va devoir
s'enfuir afin d'échapper à la gestapo à
la fin de la guerre il effectué ses
classes préparatoires d'hypokhâgne et
khâgne au lycée louis le grand
il obtient ensuite une licence de
philosophie puis une agrégation
d'histoire en 1958 il deviendra ensuite
professeur à alger puis à paris en 1977
il devient directeur de l'école des
hautes études en sciences sociales en
tant qu'auteur il écrit plusieurs
ouvrages tels que historiens public ou
liberté pour l'histoire qui sont en fait
des héritiers directs de sa formation à
savoir des ouvrages qui mêle à la fois
histoire et philosophie son travail fut
donc principalement de s'interroger sur
la place du concept d'histoire au sein
de la société
peut-être une de ses plus grandes
réalisations et la direction de l
ouvrage eu lieu de mémoire qui
théorisent que en fait finalement depuis
l'avènement des médias de masse
l'histoire s'écrit sous la pression des
mémoires collectives et le concept
d'événement monstre qu'on va essayer de
décortiquer aujourd'hui c'est sûrement
qui donc a été théorisée avant
l'avènement du libre au lieu de mémoire
est une brique importante de cette
réflexion
donc avant de préciser ce qui est
l'événement monstre on va déjà essayer
de définir ce qu'est un événement donc
l'événement selon la définition du
dictionnaire ces faits qui se produit
qui arrive à un moment donné donc bon on
perçoit bien que c'est pas très fouillé
comme définition donc on va essayer de
peut-être de lui accoler deux notions
supplémentaires déjà on peut dire que
peut-être que l'événement c'est ce qui
est capable d'attirer l'attention par
exemple fait que magloire le matin elle
mettre une ou deux secondes de plus
zappeurs bouillir l'eau que la veille
c'est un fait qui se produit pourtant
j'aurais un peu de mal à laquelle elle
catégoriser à le caractériser comme un
événement l'événement c'est aussi ce qui
se produit en dehors du cadre quotidien
c'est à dire le fait de dire que par
exemple il pleut en bretagne en novembre
est ce qu'on peut parler d'événement
peut être difficilement par contre qu'il
est plus en décembre dans le sahara là
on a quelque chose qui sort du quotidien
donc peut-être quelques troncs auraient
plus tendance à considérer et a appelé
événements dès lors la mission
journalistique et 7 prendre ces
événements là les analyses et les
traiter les hiérarchiser à prendre en
compte au public seulement on perçoit
bien que ce traitement est tout ce
processus est tout sauf linéaire et
objective
les porteurs d'informations sont
eux-mêmes porté par un nombre
incalculable d'influents qu'elle soit
interne ou externe contrat peut être
leur avis politique
la ligne éditoriale de leurs médias les
pressions liées à l'audience les
pressions économiques de fait cette
notion de subjectivité ce n'est pas un
mal en soi dans la mesure où le
journaliste justement son rôle c'est
effectivement de rapporter l'information
mais il a également un rôle de médiation
c'est à dire faire médiation entre eux
l'événement et le public donc si on
prend pour exemple une information telle
que nous hantera nucléaire a été touchée
par un tsunami
son rôle aux valises ce n'est pas de
dire seulement sept centrales nucléaires
a été touché par ce tsunami s'est aussi
expliqué quels sont les risques pour la
population qu est ce qu un tsunami ni
comment cela est arrivé
bref il a un rôle certes heures à bord
dans la compression mais aussi de
pouvoir contextualiser d'information
pour la rend plus facilement accessible
et plus facilement compréhensibles par
le cul aussi cette mission
journalistique elle tend à dépasser
l'événement afin de pouvoir le
contextualiser et de pouvoir lui
apporter une meilleure appréciation donc
qu'un aura ces questions là ça
m'intéresse pas mal et c'est surtout la
notion de comment un fait et son
traitement vont construire l'histoire
avec un grand h
donc cette réflexion va prendre un
tournant pour ternera aux alentours de
mai 68 ou en fait il va être adossé à
son balcon avec un fond réaliste
d'europe 1 et à ce moment là il va
entendre les échos des différents heures
entre les étudiants et les crs à
quelques rues de là et c est qu on lui
rappelait finalement ce qu'est
l'événement médiatique c'est à dire une
amplification du fait pour qu'elle soit
accessible immédiatement à tous cette
pensée lui fait dire que l'on peut
virtuellement dissocier le fait de son
traitement médiatique va alors dire que
le journalisme est en train de
concurrencer l'historien non pas que le
journal n va créer des faits et des
événements de toutes pièces mais
simplement que son amplification et ses
modes de médiatisation vont profondément
changer la morphologie de l'événement
le média d'où vient donc partie
intégrante de l'histoire est donc
l'événement monte à la fois cette
amplification violente de l'événement
mais également le dialogue entre
l'événement et sa médiatisation pour
comprendre on va prendre comme exemple
l'événement médiatique parmi les
événements médiatiques sénat mais le 11
septembre 2001 la particularité de cet
événement et qu'il a un rayonnement
mondial immédiat et ce peut-être et
peut-être surtout d'ailleurs qu'il est
principalement associée à l'image donc
ces images des avions qui viennent taper
sept tours du world trade center sont d
une image qui sont particulièrement
frappantes et qui vont être diffusés
quasi immédiatement à toutes les
télévisions du monde entier et donc ça
va avoir pour effet direct de créer un
très fort effet de proximité
aussi même à plusieurs milliers de
kilomètres on pouvait avoir l'impression
du coup de participer aux mêmes
événements au même moment
nora parle ici de pâtes événementialité
événement total l'événement au delà de
sa première diffusion va être répétée un
nombre incalculable de deux fois ce qui
a pour effet donc d'amplifier encore cet
événement est de le faire perdurer aussi
de faire perdurer sa charge émotionnelle
donc pierre nora a dit à ce titre que
les médias de masse fond de l'histoire
une agression et qu' ils rendent
finalement l'événement monstrueux donc
non pas monstrueux parce qu'ils sortent
de l'ordinaire mais montreux par s'en
fait leur répétition et la surabondance
d'informations une nouvelle image sur
l'événement va créer
une espèce d'envié de la société moderne
de nouveaux événements et il n'avait pas
visité de l'image donc l'événement
montre c'est un événement qui par son
traitement va constituer une force de
frappe symbolique aussi dans sa planque
en fait elle n'a pas besoin d'un
traitement médiatique hyper virulent
pour devenir quelque chose d'horrible à
la base des gens qui meurent de cette
façon là et de série club de lens là
c'est forcément le seul hic c'est
qu'avec cette répétition et cette
impression des images vraiment sûr dans
les mémoires de tous
ça va créer un événement qui devait
finalement accès que sur l'émotionnel et
que sur l'affect et un site qui va créer
aussi notre api non seulement symbolique
mais aussi idéologique
une autre thèse exprimé par nora c'est
de dire que avant l'avènement de la
piste et moderne à dire quelque chose
qui va en parallèle avec l'avènement des
médias de masse le fantastique qui
venait d'un autre monde des mondes
fantastiques
il pense qu'aujourd'hui avec l'avènement
des médias de masse le fantastique il
est intégré dans nos sociétés et il est
relaté par l'événement l'idée de nora
derrière cela c'est à dire que avec
l'avènement des nouvelles technologies
finalement on va créer un fantastique
mais qui appartient bien à notre réelle
donc pour mettre cela en exemple pierre
nora ans notamment l'exemple de
l'alunissage de neil armstrong et buzz
aldrin tutti obéissaient aux contrastes
exploiter légitimement par les
organisateurs de ce show interplanétaire
inimaginable démonstration de puissance
technique réalisée avec cette précision
contre onirique super sélectivité de 3,0
identificatoires au physique de superman
de bande dessinée l'utilisation de
l'esthétique futuriste du lem d'où
émergeaient sur le petit écran des
scaphandres aux gestes enfin délivré du
poids de la terre contraste entre les
mans cité des anges financiers humains
et politiques et la fragilité des
réflexes physique et nerveux de trois
simples hommes l'imaginaire fondée sur
la surpuissance scientifique du monde
moderne se nourrissaient ici du coup
vieux rêve de l'humanité instances du
réel intense informatrice inscrits
consommatrices marcher du même pas le
débarquement dans la lune fut le modèle
de l'événement
moderne on dit ainsi que l'événement
historique va progresser vers un
événement de masse qui est indexée sur
l'affect
le problème c'est que cette masse
représente à la fois tout le monde et
personne
ainsi en quoi l'événement mancelle
menacée l'histoire bien la tête de
l'auteur c'est de dire que en
spectacular ''sans l'événement et en
l'amplifiant qui va finalement trahir
cet événement est de faire il va
également travestir l'histoire
évidemment ce constat de l'impact
médiatique sur l'événement il doit être
considéré au vu de l'évolution
médiatique en mai 68 lorsque l'auteur
formule ce constat il n'existe que deux
chaînes télévisuelles en france
aujourd'hui
outre l'extrême multiplication des
chaînes de télévision il ya également le
bouleversements apportés par les réseaux
sociaux dans l'acheminement de
l'information on va essayer ici de
préciser trois éléments peut-être
principaux qui ont bouleversé ce
traitement médiatique de l'événement
déjà on peut émettre l'hypothèse
aujourd'hui l'acquisition de
l'information c'est vraiment un
événement commun aussi il est possible
aujourd'hui d'acquérir une information
sur un événement par un nombre
incalculable de kano c'est donc la fin
des grandes messes télévisuelle aussi
potentiellement contrairement à la ligne
sad en 69 on peut estimer que si un
atterrissage sur marc déroule dans les
prochaines années la consommation qu'on
aura des événements là sera radicalement
différente c'est à dire on pourra le
manceau mais effectivement à la
télévision on pourra regarder le stream
de la nasa
on pourra écouter youtuber qui par
exemple internet à l'espace
commentez en direct cet événement là que
l'acquisition de l'information même si
effectivement c'est le même événement se
fera potentiellement de façon différente
selon les individus l'autre évolution
c'est que le spectateur a désormais un
caractère proactif c'est à dire que il
est désormais en mesure de réagir
directement notamment dans les réseaux
sociaux à ce qui est en train de se
passer
si c'était juste ça finalement ça
changerait pas grand chose parce que
entre moi tweete ah là là c'est super
c'est en train de se passer est à dire à
quelqu'un de la famille à côté de moi ah
là là c'est incroyable qu'un enfant soit
passé c'est plus ou moins la même clause
ce qui va changer dans le traitement
médiatique là du coup c'est que
aujourd'hui les médias et les
journalistes sont des grands
consommateurs des réseaux sociaux
également c'est peut-être les mêmes des
premiers consommateurs des réseaux
sociaux et notamment de twitter
donc cette réaction du spectateur va
aussi nourrir ce traitement médiatique
et devront nécessairement s'implanter et
on a aussi de plus en plus notamment des
rubriques que ce soit dans les journaux
ou dans différentes émissions où on a
des captures d'écran de tweets ou de
réactions sur les socios avec ans en
précisant voilà qu'est ce que pensent
des réseaux sociaux de cette question là
donc ça ça change aussi nécessairement
la façon dont les médias ont de
considérer les spectateurs puisque là on
a des gens qui réagissent face à
l'événement jeu répondant à ces
critiques de cette de ce genre de ce
genre de segments c'est à dire que
pensent les réseaux sociaux de ce qu'on
peut me raconter dans la mesure où déjà
qui parle c'est à dire se sont pas les
gens à la masse qui parle
ce sont des gens sur twitter qui
réagissent et en plus ces gens sur
twitter qui réagissent c'est des gens
qui ont été sélectionnés par le média
pour parler de cette question là est
donc finalement tout ce que tu as dit
c'est voilà les gens qu'on l'a
sélectionné sur les réseaux sociaux qui
nous intéressait donc ça veut pas dire
grand chose
est ce qu'on peut dire que ça nourrit
vraiment l'information et où même que ça
précise la réaction des téléspectateurs
ou des spectateurs
il ya cette information on peut en
douter mais ça ça change en rien le fait
qu'effectivement le spectateur pour se
sentir non pro actif face à la situation
et que aucun doute sur le fait que les
médias se nourrissent de cette activité
sur internet pour concevoir leurs
propres réactions et éventuellement pour
construire l'information en fonction de
cette de ces réactions troisième
changement fondamental qui a par rapport
à ce premier constat de nos races et que
le filtrage de l'information est
évidemment bouleversé c'est à dire que
avant l'avènement de mende
sociaux et de toute cette cheminée de
l'information il y avait des barrières à
l'entrée c'est à dire que effectivement
il y avait une information qui était co
construit par des professionnels
médiatique des choses qui étaient
vérifiées et qui était transmise par
seth
l'instance journalistique à la
problématique aujourd'hui c'est que ces
filtres sont absents arbitre pas disparu
mais en tout cas ils ont profondément
reculé
donc on ne retrouve pas situation où
c'est plus temps une ligne éditoriale ou
une mission d'information guide
l'acheminement de l'événement et
éventuellement sa transmission mais bien
ce qui intéresse et ce qui frappe les
gens qui réagissent et donc on se
retrouve face à des situations où c'est
plus tant ceux qui méritent d'être mis
sur l'événement qui est transmis mais
bien ceux qui a envie d'être écouté et
ça ça peut être une problématique alors
l'idée et va nous dire que les médias
sont pas toujours été parfait et
parfaitement et ont parfaitement rempli
leur mission d'information
mais simplement sans fil et sans
barrières à l'entrée dans cette
transmission de l'information
on peut peut-être faire l'hypothèse que
c'est plutôt l'émotionnel et l'affect
qui va encore plus construire
l'événement que sa rationalité son
impact réel sur le social et surtout ce
qu'il emporte la seconde problématique
est que cette viralité
elle entraîne également la diffusion de
fausse information
news c'est une information qui pour le
coup n'a pas d'origine réel mais qui
circulent parce que soit elle a un
intérêt idéologique pour ce qu'il a
diffusées pour ceux qui la partagent
ou alors parce que l intéresse elle
questionne et que potentiellement ceux
qui la transmettent n'ont pas les
compétences pour pouvoir porter un et
critique sur l'information qui est qui a
déposé
you wake 2 si on reprend un peu
d'émotion
nora c'est un écho une amplification n'a
pas de source d'origine
évidemment ça cette interprétation elle
est relativement personnel donc je vous
invite à dans les commentaires abîmer
votre désaccord si c'est le cas on va
apporter des précisions sur les suites
donc voilà pour ce sixième épisode
j'espère qu'il vous aura plu comme
d'habitude vous l'été avec deux
références pour pouvoir approfondir la
thématique cela vous intéresse
le premier c'est un article qui m'a pas
mal aidé pour pouvoir constituer cette
émission qui est la fabrique de
l'histoire moderne par françois dosse
qui est justement un retour sur le
concept de l'événement montre par pierre
nora et une réactualisation finalement
aussi de cette notion on regarde de
l'évolution à médiatique et franchement
hyper intéressante
en second lieu je vous invite à regarder
l'émission comment s'assurer de la
fiabilité de l'information alors des
faits que news qui a été réalisée par
l'émission la tronche-en-biais qui est
une super émission de 8 à 60 il invite à
regarder cette émission et les autres si
ça vous intéresse
encore merci de m'avoir écouté sur ce je
vous souhaite une superbe journée et
soirée et nuit tout ce que vous voulez
et on dit à la prochaine salut
oui alors oui peut être ouais trop bien
non l'émission s'est très bien passé
jusqu'au bout de temps c'est de très
intelligent été captivés cédant c'était
très intéressant
les gens des gens qui datent dehors de
la majorité voilà ce qui perd donc non
je te dirai quel point